gt i'm super excited about this because
i have so much good stuff
okay so i got this new thing
so i call this file nintendo rev it's
basically
revenue from a fake game company called
nintendo
um
you never heard of it because it doesn't
exist okay so
library gt we need that we've got to
have it and then go to library nintendo
it's a hard package to get it's on
github if you just search it up you will
find it and the cool thing about it is
it has data sets of different sizes
and we'll use one of those data sets for
this
it'll be so nice uh and i like to
library in tidyverse because we're going
to use all sorts of tidy bursts before
making the actual table
um
the data table and then we're going to
get in blooper day because we're going
to do some date and time stuff and i'm
never sure whether that's included in
diverse i think it isn't
okay so great
um so i'm gonna get all the revenue just
by
you know assigning it to this
and
okay so nintendo has a bunch of like dss
um
like all revenue all sessions uh i'm
gonna get the revenue
uh so i'm gonna do that right here uh
the default options are good this is
like the size of the data set we'll just
go for a small because we don't wanna
like you know tax the system too much
so we're gonna get the data
doing some stuff here but it just
downloads the data from the repo and now
we can totally see it i'm going to make
the console just a bit bigger because
we'll do some console stuff initially
so lots of rows of data like nearly 2
000
200 000 whoa
okay it's a lot of revenue this
company's doing well
which is great uh good for nintendo
um
but it has lots of countries in it
um and we're gonna
filter down this data quite a bit
we're gonna actually make something
super narrow so in the end we definitely
don't want
more than like 50 rows i think to fit a
table on the screen so we're gonna make
we're going to happily summarize this so
first thing we're going to do
is make a vector
uh first up setting the countries
okay
so i'll just say countries to consider
so i'll call it countries
then i'm just going to make a vector of
countries i know using like the two
letter codes so i'm just
i think it's us
great britain
uh we'll put in d e
c h we'll make it a top eight
uh
norway
this is canada
then we'll do
india
and spain which is es
so that's eight right yeah that's
totally a perfect i'll keep on the same
line
good so now we have this this is some
sort of prep work we need to do
so we have that
now we need to get
um
well first of all we have all these
times for the revenue we want to break
it down to like just like each month
we're going to summarize for each month
what the revenue was for each type of
revenue
uh just go over this table a bit so i'll
tell you exactly what this but this all
is so each player in the game has an id
each time they play the game they have a
session and that has an id as well
there's a session start
and the time of the revenue
event so each row is a revenue event
like a purchase of something
and they can buy
either an iep which is an in-app
purchase usually some sort of like
currency or secondary currency or some
game item
or some special offer that's a
combination of things
and then there's revenue associated with
that you know with that bought item
and actually there's two different types
there's also like
uh
item name might be
like um
iep or ads so ad views will also result
in some revenue as well
okay and then there's a session duration
so just amount of time they were in that
session it's good analytics to have see
how long they're playing and what
triggered the sale
uh a start date this is like historical
data it's a start date for that player
so we can get the player age from that
so it's kind of like a redundant thing
but it's good to have because you can
sort of segment all this data by the
player age
and then we have other things to do with
the player like their acquisition
uh basically where they're required from
like what ad
caused him to play the game or convert
into the game so it could be like other
networks like facebook or ads on
different platforms that got them into
the game
usually they represented with a link and
then they're
they install the app that way the game
and then the country they're from which
is basically uh
some course location data which is just
provided by max mind
okay so we have all that so now we
really wanted to just break this down
into like country
uh month
uh item type and then the total revenue
and we're gonna make a table from that
it's gonna be really pretty sweet okay
so now we've got the countries
considered we explained the data a
little bit there
uh so now we want to get the month names
because
in the end we'll just have like one two
three total twelve as the column names
uh but we won't make them you know like
friendlies or like nice month names
so we'll do that um
i just found this out today actually uh
there's like
a month named vector in r
which is kind of cool uh but we just
need the first three letters
so we'll do like substring
from one to three
and we'll see that that gives us just
this
and then later on we need this as a list
to change the column names in gt
which is a little bit inconvenient but
that might change later but we'll just
make it a list like this
okay
great so now we'll just get this
i don't really like lists because
they're kind of like annoying but
uh we have no choice so we have to make
this list so we'll call this month means
like so
and another sort of weird thing about gt
is it needs a name to list because it
has to map the column name with the new
label so these will act as labels but we
need the name of each item in the list
as like the actual column name
so that's not too bad uh because we know
there's gonna be one one to twelve so
let's just names month names
uh so many names
as character
uh
one to twelve
okay so now if we do this
and we take a look at month names we
finally have this
preparation step right here
this will be good for later uh just
doing it ahead of time
as you know it's kind of annoying to
deal with it later
okay so now all the
revenue okay we're gonna start there
we're gonna build up this table like one
line at a time maybe bunches of lines at
a time but we'll see it every step of
the way so right now we don't even have
it in gt we just we still have this
um and we still do lots of stuff before
we get the gt
for instance we need to do that month
thing so we'll do mutate
month is going to equal
looper date
and then we want to use the month
function
and we want to use it on the time column
right there that's the time of the
revenue event okay i'm just going to run
this
uh you won't see it because it's
actually at the end but trust me it's
just like the month as a number
okay continue
filter we're going to filter a lot
because we don't need a ton of stuff in
this table uh because we want to focus a
bit there's lots of data in this table
but we want to just focus on a few
things otherwise it gets too
multi-dimensional
so we'll say item type
is going to be just the iep type and
again it's in that purchase people it
thinks people buy and not adds people
watch
okay so that brings down the table down
to 47 000 rows
which is a lot better than before
um
one thing we don't see here and this is
a second note from the data is the
country is like a long country name it's
not a country code
which is fine but it's kind of big and
it's kind of hard to work with
a weird thing about gt is it actually
has this
country pops data set
uh which has great data but the cool
thing is it has a bunch of country names
and the country codes and they just
happen to map perfectly with this data
set so we can actually like do a join
and get the country codes from this
uh
and you get the two letter country codes
um either one is good but just for this
one i'm just going to work with that
so i'm going to do a
left join
because i want to join that table on the
existing data that is in what we have
here
and it's going to be gt country pops
the data set and we're going to filter
that just by those first two columns
so country
name
and what is the other one uh country
code two
great so we filter that down
uh now you just get like those two
columns we'll just make that distinct so
we have you know just like
you know like 100 or so 170 universal
rows
and then uh we'll do buy because it'll
be two different names
and i believe construction is the c and
then two quarter things this is the left
side like
are all the revenue table and this is
the country pop side
so this side is going to be
country
name
and this one will be i think just
country forever yeah country okay let's
run this now and see if it works
it totally works we got country code two
in there
we'll change all those names later
promise you that
uh so we did a left join there's a ton
of stuff we do before we get to a table
i know but you know we've got
so much yeah we have we have no choice
okay now we're gonna do another mutate
okay and the thing i'm gonna do here is
say
okay so we have this ieps i'm gonna
stretch this out just a little bit so we
can see here um because it's almost
impossible to see what we have in terms
of types
there we go item names so we have like
different tiers of gold offer and i
think
there's not just gold there's also like
gems i believe
um but we just want to lump it together
into like one type so all we gotta do is
like take off the digit and
we don't do any regular expressions or
anything just take off the digit
um
oh no we do have to do a regular
expression
we have to identify the vision and just
take it off okay but this is super
simple so we're going to call this iep
type as a new thing
and we're just going to do a g sub
then we're going to look for any digit
so just 0 9 and it's only just one so we
don't have to put any star here like
that and then we're just going to like
replace it with nothing
and then that's going to be item name
okay let's see that this actually worked
great it didn't error which is fantastic
we got iap type and i'm trusting that
this number is gone so that sort of lump
scenes together so we have like
you know less less dimensions to worry
about
okay continuing
we're going to select a few things to
really narrow down this table so we
actually can see our one screen
uh so we're going to select the country
and
that is currently as country code 2
great
and then the other things we're going to
select our month
iep type and most we need item revenue
of course
in that order because like these will be
things we group on and then the last
thing will just be the thing we want to
summarize okay let's look at this now
great much
much shorter much less wide
still lots of rows but summary will take
care of that uh summer as well
so we're going to group by
basically all the things like month
uh iep type
then country
i'm gonna pass that into summarize
uh we're gonna call this total rev
and it's just gonna be the sum
of item
revenue and then there's like this
groups argument that i always forget to
select or to use it always gives me a
warning so i'm just gonna use it now and
i think it's drop is what you want i'll
put on the second line
then it's closed off okay let's take a
look now much less rows i'm hoping
no okay sorry
i don't use the shortcut because i just
never did do that and maybe that's the
case for doing it okay much less 765
plus 10 rows 775.
that is great okay so now we're going to
arrange stuff
it's always good to arrange it and sort
of see like you know things make sense
um so i'm going to arrange by month
country
and iep type and particularly again
great and arranging is actually super
important before you get into like gt
anyways because you're going to have
like arranged data in gt
some things you can change though um
but it's good to sort of arrange it you
know a bit because it's for display
okay now we arranged it we're going to
use pivot wire
to take the months and put them as
columns
okay so pivot wider
okay and i believe this is names from
and then values from
let's select it down here
so the names are for a month
in quotes
no i don't think you need to put quotes
values from
total
f
great now we're going to see the table
being super wide i'm hoping yes
so we unfortunately have like column
names in numbers but they're in
backticks so they're okay to access that
way and you can actually even in gte
access and buy like
uh just like
like quoted numbers
so it's not too bad so now we have this
we're going to pipe that into
gt finally and we'll see how this looks
i'm going to
bring this up so we can actually see the
table
okay great so now we have a gt table
finally
we're gonna make this a bit wider
so now we can see that we have all the
stuff in here which is great it's a bit
long
but we can totally change this um
one thing we might note is that
the structure is fine
but we have things which are great for
grouping we have like names here for
rows and we have groups which are the
countries so in the gt
call itself we have rho name call and
grouping call we use both
so for wrong call we're going to use in
quotes
it's going to be uh iap type
and for group name call
it's going to be country
great okay so now running this it gets
arranged a little bit differently
so now we have like this which is kind
of cool now we have countries like this
they're not arranged in a way that we
maybe wanted to be arranged but we can
sort of fix that
okay oh also i don't want maybe all
these countries here because we do have
the countries considered so we didn't
actually filter before but that's cool
because like with uh
you know with this code we can
definitely just
like change it and then like
you know it's all good uh so i think
it's
country at this point yeah country
in
countries
considered yeah you join it with pipe
now this table because we're just
writing this code should
be plus countries now
great that's perfect
okay so now it's like less
less big of a table it's kind of like
focused a bit
okay so now we have this we're going to
continue on
so now we have a table at least so we're
in run table territory in gt now we can
do all sorts of things to like shape it
while we're in the gt api
um
one thing you might want is like the
countries to be in order that we want
just because uh we decided beforehand
you know these are largest
more important at the top in terms of
revenue
there's actually a function in gt that's
maybe less well-known it's called row
group order
it's just for changing the order of like
these row groups and you just do that by
a vector of the names of the row groups
and luckily they have that it's
basically just
countries considered
[Music]
it's considered great now if we run this
we should get it in the order yeah
exactly usgb de
perfect that's what we want and this is
important it's not if you want in
exactly the order you want and it's kind
of frustrating to put in that order
there's other ways to do it beforehand
but this is a nice easy way of doing it
in gt
great so we have root group order
now we're going to do like a ton of
stuff just to like uh make the table
present well
uh it has lots of things so one thing we
might do is format the numbers so
they're actually in currencies right now
this is just like
usd amounts
uh but they don't look like that so
we'll use form at
currency
and the cool thing about that is
you can just
use columns equals to everything
and then all columns which are here in
the body will be formatted as such
and you do have like this currency
uh
argument but it's already set to usd so
we don't do anything there
uh one thing we might do is we don't
really need the pennies involved so we
just might say use subunits equal or
false
and let's see what that looks like
right not bad that's pretty good that's
more what you want because like these
are big figures you don't really care
about the sense it's kind of like
you know it's just rounded essentially
in this case
good okay so now we have that formatting
in place
uh if we scroll down
we see we have some any values
so while we're doing formatting you can
actually use a formatter called format
missing
so it's fmt missing
and if you just use that on everything
so the first argument is columns
i just use that everywhere okay so use
everything and then it will do is it'll
go in and find every n a and just use
the default replacement text you can set
it but by default it's this m dash which
is quite nice
again you can send with any word it is
marked down it's totally up to you but
the default is pretty good
okay so that's before i'm missing
um
another new feature in gt which is kind
of cool um
it it's basically in the last release of
gt
is you can take these row groups and
make them columns
so it's a little hard to access that
it's actually in tab options but i'm
going to show you how to do that
so it's actually tab options and
tab options it's just got
so many different options that you
probably wanted to have to see what they
are you can actually search you can
actually search do a fuzzy search in
here
um the option that we need is row group
um
there it is as column and then you just
use a true by default it's false but we
want true in this case
okay
so now it looks like this so we have row
groups but now they're to the side and
it kind of displays nicely because you
just have like this
just sort of like these groups these
bundles of rows which are nice
great so now we have that um the thing
we gotta do now is take those numbers
in you know the top and make those month
names
and we have that which is great we have
this
month names list right here
and what you can do in um
calls label which is the thing you use
to relabel the column names is you can
pass in a list so it's like this dot
list argument
so that list will be
this right here this month names list
so if you just pass that in
i believe that's all you gotta do um
let's run this
yeah now we get the months as like these
short three letter months which is great
better than numbers i'd say
okay so we have a table that's looking
like it's developing pretty well
um
one thing we can do and
it's always fun to do that is add some
context to what these months are or
maybe there's special things about these
months so you can add spanners above
column names
we do have a tab spanner
right here
and
just some use if you're using a
development version of gt
we now have the ability to have multiple
spanners uh previously you can only have
like one level spanners but if you're
using the development version i
definitely encourage that um
you get multiple spanners which is great
i'll show you how to create multiple
spanners in a very logical and easy to
use way
so tavis banner the first thing you want
to do is
well say what year this is i know it's
kind of ridiculous but we will say this
is
label
2015.
and this is like fake data i just give
the year of 2015. i don't know why uh
but that's what it is so we'll then
we'll use
columns okay and we'll span this over
every column with everything like that
okay 2015. great okay
uh and
since this is fake data i can just make
up stuff everywhere we'll add some more
spanners
and we'll just say like the first three
months
there's a certain version of like this
this game out like version 1.0
so we'll call this
label
v
0.1
and the columns won't be everything
um
they will actually be
c and
backtick one two and three
i'll show you two styles of doing this
but these are actually the names of the
columns themselves
in the original data okay so i'll get
rid of this
and we'll see that
this now appears over those first three
columns which is great
so now we're going to do the rest what
version was the next one i think 1.2
let's get 1.1
we'll just put that then
okay so 1.2
and
we can access columns a different way we
can just say 4 to 12.
but they can't be numbers they have to
be a character
so we'll do this right here as character
great so i just just like know it gives
you this
so if you run the whole thing
we now get this
great now we have like two levels of
spanners which is kind of cool it gives
you extra context about like you know
this is child 15 these are the months
and this is some extra information about
what version of the game was out during
these months
okay
great now we have that we should put a
header in this table so we can identify
and you know just give it a nice title
and subtitle
so we do that with tab header
and
there's two things you put in here a
title and a subtitle subtitle is
optional but it's always nice to have
i'm going to call this revenue
amounts
by country
iep types
let's do iptype
great subtitle
we can make that
we can use markdown
so inside here we can have markdown text
which is and it'll be formatted as such
so we'll say this considers
um
so this will be bold top eight
entries
all right overall
we have to close this off
i'll put this down below for clarity
like so let's run this
and we'll see a title
looks good markdown did carry over which
is nice uh sorry i have an extra parent
i'll get rid of that
uh one thing we can do is if this is
like not enough space between like you
know like the the rest of the table we
can because we're using markdown we can
throw in some like line breaks
so vr like so
if putting two to actually force like
this you know that amount of area
but we'll see
if this is good some people may like
this have a little bit of extra
breathing room before we actually get to
the table so that's a nice little trick
you can use
great so now we have the header
we could do things like there's these
opt functions like opt align table
header
you may want to left so there's an
option here just to align it to the left
i mean it gives a nice look as long as
you style everything else to be sort of
like you know to go with this
uh it could be good
okay uh one thing we're missing is this
large gulf of space we don't have to put
anything there but it's kind of a sign
there it's basically a it's called this
is the stub essentially so this is
called the stub head
uh we can actually just put a label
there
and we also use markdown just like we
did before to do that so this is tab
stub head
and the only argument is label
and we'll use markdown
and we'll say region
and ap type
and again if you want to force a line
break because we're using martian you do
it right in the middle here if you want
you don't just want to guarantee that
this breaks there
so let's take a look here
great
excellent so okay so we got that now um
now we can style this thing uh quite a
bit because
right now it's just like a plain table i
mean it looks fine it has all the
information but
there's not a whole heck of a lot of
style here
so let's dial a little bit first and
then look into like coloring the data as
well because that's always fun and good
to do
okay so we use tab style this is the
thing where you target different areas
of the table and you apply a style
okay so in this case i just want to make
all the text a little bit smaller in the
in the body of the table
there's kind of overwhelmingly large so
i'm just going to do that right now so
i'm going to say it's going to be style
cell text
and we'll say the size there's a bunch
of arguments but size is one of them but
here's the list of arguments
and this is like html thing like a css
thing you just say smaller and it'll
just make it a bit smaller than the
default
and with
tab style you always have to put
locations
so in this case i will use
cells
body if you're targeting all the cells
in the body you have to put any
arguments it's already targeting
everything so let's run this
and we'll see that this becomes just a
little bit smaller
yeah and now it actually fits like
width-wise into like because right now
we're just sizing everything by like the
size of the content
uh but now making it smaller it makes it
a bit a little bit nicer like these are
a bit larger
these are maybe less important
especially as you color the you know
like the cells themselves to become a
little bit less important
okay so now we have tab style we did
that
uh the next thing we do is we're like i
said we're going to color all the cells
so we use the call like the function
called data color
okay
really kind of tough to use uh i always
recommend going to the help
uh data color
like so
i mean i could barely remember how to
use it because it involves using scales
functions inside of it for the colors
argument
okay luckily there's examples in here
and they show how they work but
uh it's always a bit of a challenge you
know even for me
okay but for this we know we need a few
arguments that we see here
um
so we're going to use
columns first
we're going to use we're going to
consider all the columns
all the body columns in the table
which is great uh and then we're gonna
use scales
called numeric
that's a function from scales
palette
okay this is gonna be a little bit
strange but i'm using two greens
and the first screen i'm going to use is
66ff i'll make that capital ff
zero zero
and
this is a little bit strange i use the
same color
for like you know the high
amount
except
i'm going to use alpha
the strange thing about like uh alpha
and scales called numeric is you don't
provide alpha value you provide true or
false and where you provide the alpha
thing is right here in the color itself
so
you can make color names like have an
alpha part so
zero alpha is is there so this is like
the low value
and the complete opaque one is ff
okay very strange
the way you do it but it makes sense it
just says whether you consider
the alpha part of the color
okay
okay great uh so and also we're going to
choose an n a
color um just a random color let's see
uh
okay maybe one more half and six six is
that right one two three four five six
seven eight okay good
and what else oh yeah the most important
one is domain and this is where you can
choose the limits like the range of like
where the colors go if you just want it
to be the data itself you just use null
okay that simplifies things a bit
okay is that it i hope that's it oh yeah
it seems like that's it so you didn't
provide columns you need to provide like
a function here
uh this argument is called
colors unfortunately
uh but if you have that
then you're good to go so i'm gonna like
run this and hope that it just works
okay
it does which is great so you can see
here that like the values here are
colored
um dark greens are like high values
these are like you know like low sort of
like almost transparent greens are like
less values
so just a way to sort of map around you
know see if revenue has grown
during you know months that we've you
know like had the game
and uh you know in which regions like
the revenue is not so great you see here
and any color is right here so basically
any any values are
in this color
uh so that's good otherwise i think it'd
be a dark gray and maybe that's just not
driving with the color scheme here
okay so that's the color
great uh so now we're gonna do things
like
fill up the table a bit more uh so we're
gonna add source nodes so you do that by
add let's start with tab source node
and for each source node you add you
you basically make a new call of tab
source node
okay and the argument here is source
node
and again you can use markdown for this
and we can just say like the source of
the data we just got this is all pretend
we'll just say all revenue
uh figures
obtained
uh from daily
retrievals
from the again we have markdown so we'll
just say
api
there's a period
i believe that closes it off let's run
this
okay then we have to go right to the
bottom to see it
there it is which is great and this is
italicized which is fantastic okay so
we're gonna keep keep going with this
uh we'll add another source node just to
show you that
and add a whole bunch and they go in the
order that you specify them in
uh and this one will say
yeah i guess it will start with all
just gonna like get rid of this
yeah all reporting
uh ship here
was created
by the and again you can use like crazy
markdown like this
italics and bold
uh we'll say central
data science team
so let's run this
and again we'll scroll to the bottom
and see that it was added and it's in
the same order which is
wonderful
and
we're going to add some footnotes now
we're just going to fill up this footer
and then we can sort of see that you
know like interesting things could be
like
shown there and like you can have put
out references in the table and
you know it kind of like adds a bit more
context where you might need it so just
have footnote
uh in this case you need an argument
which is footnote and locations so it's
kind of like to have style where you
need the locations so it's going to put
that in for now
but the footnote here might be um
well let's maybe like put footnotes on
like where there's like missing data and
we'll explain it i think that's not a
bad idea okay we'll say that these
figures
are zero dollars
or less
we can say due to
refunds
yeah which is totally a possibility
um
and locations so if you have multiple
locations
like we have two different columns we
can make a list of locations like so
and we just you know separate the
each of the
cells calls with a comma
okay so cell's body
and we'll say first one is in columns
equal to one
that's our original column name
and we have to sort of like say which
rows they are in this case we'll say
rows equals is n a
and
like so
unfortunately we have to do twice um
because we have two different columns
and we can't just refer to the column
like in this rows expression
uh but you know it's not too bad that
maybe that may change later on
so in this case we know there's one in
month three so we have to do this
great
and hopefully this works i'm gonna run
it to see if it does
okay it didn't complain and we do see a
footnote right there
great and we do see it in the right
places it's not anywhere else besides
the nas
which is great i love that
okay more footnotes yeah i mean like
just like one footnote not great so
we're gonna add a few more i know it's a
little bit tedious but um
you're gonna love all the footnotes i
swear to you okay tab
great
okay
in this case um
let's see it was a good one um
something notable
okay right here norway like there's a
huge jump
in like the revenue
i mean maybe we should explain this okay
so let's do that let's target this cell
with a footnote
and some explanation so footnote
is going to be uh
holding this markdown just for fun
surprising jump in
jumps in bold
uh revenue
from the previous
month
okay period and we'll put a comma
on the outside
is that right yes and now we need a
location so let's say locations
is going to be
cells body
columns will be the 12th month
okay and this one's a bit tricky because
usually you can specify by like the
like the label here but they're all the
same
which is like makes it possible it's
just jem's gold offer gems gold offer oh
okay so we can't do that so we have to
actually use an expression
and we have to like make sure it is just
for this cell
[Music]
which is not great but we will do it so
we'll do we'll say rose it's going to
equal because it's on that column um
basically just how we got the value
we'll just put the value in round 12
equal to
6278
[Music]
okay
that means you know
i mean i can't think of another way dude
so this is not bad this is not bad
okay so hopefully
yeah i see it's right there and it's
nowhere else because no other value
is that value
great
good so now we have two footnotes
i specified you know in order i wanted
and it just appeared in the right order
which is
awesome
gotta have it okay now we're gonna add
even more formulas
but we can explain what these version
numbers are and i swear we're gonna get
we're gonna finish the footnotes after
that
um because i like to have a bunch of
footnotes because
you know more numbers and we can do more
stuff in there like i said before
so tab footnote
note
is going to equal um we'll just say like
the
and i'll put this in backtext i'll make
it a code font like so
we'll say the version 1.0 build
used the first
version
of the
offer
agent
sdk
uh because we're gonna explain that you
know
the offers were pretty bad up until like
the second version came out just
coincidentally it's kind of like
it picked up
so we'll say the offer system is was
broke
initially okay so we got that
put a comma on the outside because this
is the markdown part
locations and this will be
cells
colon spanners
and this is going to be spanners
equal to exactly the label or 1.0
uh this is actually the id uh but the
label becomes the id
so and you can specify an id if you want
but usually you just want the label to
be the id for you know easiness is sake
okay we do the exact thing i'm just
going to copy this
to explain the 1.2 part
and it's really just like changing this
um say the 1.2 build
what did it do it added more
well
it got better um let's say it added
more missions basically get free dlc
uh more missions and
had an updated
offer
agent
sdk
great that's closed off and we'll say
spanners 1.2
that's what it's called okay so i'm
going to run this and we should get way
more footnotes than we've ever seen
uh four footnotes
great i see them here one two
and then there should be like a third
here great and then repeating fours
and there they all are
great this is so great
i'm loving this table so far i mean it
looks so great i mean oh yeah this is
fake yeah which is real yeah because
like
this is too good to be to be fake okay
anyways so let's keep going um one thing
i like to do is change the widths of all
the columns
like just right away i don't want
i would be left up to chance okay so
i'll just say everything
is going to be
75 pixels wide and let's take a look at
that this is something you do and you
you just adjust it all the time
oh no it does not work
yeah okay so be careful here not to use
just everything
it's not calling me
great thank you um
yeah now we should see yes this looks
great
now everything is that width which is
perfect
um here's a crazy trick um
it's a trick where like you want to
specify the column widths of these
but they don't come with column names
really um
you can just use a number like one and
now i should refer to this not this
it's a little bit strange but
by column widths it assumes everything
is is a column now and we're just going
to change everything so we do one and
make this a bit smaller so px 50
comma
okay
so now that first one should be
narrowed down if we see it shrunk down a
little bit which is good
okay
a recent version of gt added a bunch of
new functions for padding
uh they're all an opt
the opt series of functions one's called
opt horizontal padding
and we'll do a thing where we scale it
to be
um
no like more padding
and i'll show you where i'm going with
this because we have like all the values
like butting up against the edge you
know a little bit of space but we want
to maybe center it a bit i think it
might look nice so let's try it
so this will take all the data in here
basically all
the cells it'll just sort of bring stuff
in see now it's more towards the center
but still very aligned it's kind of nice
and this is actually brought in as well
so everything lines up it's really nice
like everything's
one function it just scales up having
and this could be between
uh zero and one as well if you wanted
you know to be like less pattern so
that's how that works okay uh
while we're on the padding tip uh we
just use opt vertical padding as well
because you know why not and we'll try
to get this like a bit a little more
dense so we'll say the scale in this
case
is smaller but we have less padding in
the vertical direction
okay so we should see
a bit of a tightening which is great
which is great i'm gonna make this a bit
bigger let me see more of this
good this is really shaving out
okay so we did the padding thing
and now we want to do even more style
stuff it's um
i guess we'll do some more tap style
um
because i think we want to change now is
the row groups themselves
yeah we want to maybe differentiate like
these like categories
uh so let's do that right now so we'll
say tab style
and uh
we'll make
we'll make it on the locations which
equals two cells
row groups
and this just means all of them
and the first argument is actually the
style itself
we want to change the text and the
background so we'll do put in a list and
make sure it's a comma
uh cell text
we'll say the color of the text is going
to be
a css color called snow
the weight will make it bold
and
we'll align it to the right it may not
make much of a difference but
uh
let's try it out okay so we have that um
now we'll do cell
fill
and now we want the color
to be
slate gray i'm doing caps because that's
how it is in css uh but you can do it in
all lowercase it's the same thing
and we'll add an alpha that's actually
an argument here of zero five so it
blends a bit nicely with the background
we may add
in the future okay so let's add this
it takes a little while but it's worth
it so now we have this
great
good stuff
uh now we'll do another thing there's
like this another opt function called
off to all caps
it just adds a bit more style it makes
the surrounding chrome
in a sort of like
caps type of
style
like a small caps
it's not too bad
okay i sometimes add that because it's
kinda nice
and now uh we can change the font with
opt
table font
uh and we can use the font which is a
google font
and we can just choose a name
and i know there's a bunch there's a few
ones one i like is carla
so we'll add that in we'll see immediate
change in the table
looks really good i kind of like this
and now to finish it off
we'll just add like a ton of like
different options
uh in the table because there's so many
things you can do
uh i might go very quickly through this
but options i recommend
hitting tab
you can search through there's little
descriptions here
um but we'll just change things to make
things a little bit nicer in the table
uh so we'll do the table background
color
there
and we'll choose
lemon shivan
uh great
okay good that's a you know maybe a bit
too too bright one thing we can do we
have this function in gt called adjust
luminance
we can wrap the color in it
and there's an argument there
which i believe is called steps
and we can make that too
and this could be totally adjusted
uh to suit what you think is good
okay great i'm gonna make this a little
bit bigger so we can see the rest okay
great so that's that
i'm gonna make even more options here
uh so heading background color
i'm gonna do the same sort of thing uh
except i'll just keep
lemon shivan without the change
um
another thing i'll try is
uh footnotes background colors i'm just
changing a bunch of background colors
here
uh i'm just going to put them in here
and then change them all at once
okay footnotes
and then i want source notes background
color
great
just prepping it up um
what else could we do we can just copy
this here
and just change the amount of steps it's
not a bad thing then we have a variation
on like one color so in this case i
think i might bring it back
minus
0.5
and
maybe the same thing here because
they're actually separate locations i'm
going to run this you can actually see
what's going on there
and we'll zoom to the bottom so you can
see what colors have been changed
okay so right here it's a bit darker
um it's kind of like almost similar to
this
great okay a few more things that's
where
this will do it uh so you might want to
do a thing where you cap the table on
the top and bottom you can change the
table
uh border like the very top and bottom
border
so i think it's table border um let's do
top
uh
with yeah
and we can use the function px to find
pixels just put it there
and we do the same thing with the table
border
bottom width
sorry
great so now we have those
okay another thing we do is footnotes
um there's this multi-line option now in
gt
right now there's there are multiple
lines by default we can just say false
and all appears one paragraph which is
kind of cool
another cool thing we can do is table
body
h lines
style
we can change the style of the lines
themselves because there's quite a few
lines uh we'll just make it dotted
you also do dashed and no solid is the
default
um
what else we can change the heading
title
font size
do something pretty big px30
and we do the same thing with the
heading
subtitle font size make that a bit
smaller this just bumps up in size
okay after all this let's take a look at
our table this may
be the final table
i mean i did a lot to this so let's make
this a little wide we sort of see what
we've done this is now huge but it's
nice because it's a bit bigger than the
rest makes it more tidal like
uh this looks pretty good see the dots
there's different sizes of dots a little
hard to see because the contrast but
you know it sort of lightens things a
bit and again we have the footnotes
they're all one paragraph
uh just for the footnotes part source
notes you can change the way that that
is laid out uh but in this case we did
not do that we just have them as
you know separate lines it's multi-line
equals true but we can set that to false
if you want a paragraph
[Music]
yeah and this is our table uh
not too bad
if you have real data it's even better
but fake data is always great to have
because
you know what you're gonna do you don't
have data you need to you need to get
some so
okay so that's my uh my that's my gte
demo for today
hope you enjoyed
[Music]
you